this too I find his ball out by the
trash can in a weird like Hobbit bag
yeah like I wouldn't notice his hand
woven 8th century Hobbit bag this dude
thinks he's so smart didn't that happen
oh yeah it happened
um can I uh can I tell you something I
never told you before
I don't think I'm smart I know I'm smart
and I know you're stupid because you
found the decoy bomb
wait wait that makes no sense did you
ever even like look at the bomb closely
no okay it didn't work it was broke I
knew you were snooping and so I decided
to plant something somewhere to where I
knew you would find it and then think
you found everything and not go look for
the actual bong in the actual stash that
was just sitting in my room for 10 years
[Applause]
but I know I'm smarter than you what's
up